[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sur cette opération de la pépinière de
préfiguration de corneville seul paysage
nous sommes le maître d'oeuvre sur cette
opération
donc c'est une opération qui consiste à
fournir des arbres pour le plateau de
saclay dans les différentes phases
d'aménagement qui vont venir dans les
années qui arrivent et donc en fait ce
projet de pépinière
il a vocation déjà à constituer un
paysage transitoire c'est à dire que
pendant que l'aménagement du plateau se
déroule on a déjà une installation d'un
paysage temporaire qui a aussi une
vocation par la suite à fournir les
différents végétaux et et arbres qui
seront plantés sur les espaces futur les
espaces publics de la zac à la fois du
moulon la zac de l'école polytechnique
et la zac de corneville sur ce carré de
pépinières on a planté un peu plus de
deux mille sujets qui vont être en
culture pendant deux saisons
le premier arrachage aura lieu en
2023/2024 sur la période hivernale et le
deuxième arrachage et le dernier aura
lieu
2024 2025 super bleus pépinière et je
suis la personne qui s'occupe de la
pépinière ici qu'on a créée avec le
groupe symphonia le groupe symphonia c5
pépinière en france qui sont producteurs
et qui essaye de promouvoir l'activité
de la production des arbres et des
arbustes et des plans de dexter en
france l'objectif était qu à terme on
est des arbres qui passe une taille
donnée lors de l'appel d'offres donc on
a planté ici des petits sujets qu'on
appelle des jeunes arbres avec
l'objectif de les faire pousser de les
faire grandir en hauteur en taille de
branche et en taille de tron pour les
fournir aux futurs d'entreprise de
paysages qui travaillent sur le plateau
de saclay l'objectif de la pépinière et
de produire des arbres dans un milieu
assez similaire à l'endroit où les
arbres on allait donc un milieu où le
sol va être le même que le sol des
chantiers entoure le but de la pépinière
c'était le maître des essences assise
locale
donc on a planté du boulot du phallus
duchesne et de l'érable
c'est des essences qui sont endémiques
de la région et qu'on va essayer de
produire ici et de hordes de beaux
sujets à la taille demandé aux marchés
l'objectif est de produire des végétaux
dans les conditions climatiques
similaires à l'endroit futur l'eydap
seront plantés pour l'éternité
[Musique]